Gavin new one point tried to say that
California was the freedom say I just
kind of laugh like you're locking people
down you're doing all this then I
thought about it you know California
does have freedoms uh that some people
don't uh that other states don't you
have the freedom to defecate in public
in California you have the freedom to
pitch a tent on Sunset Boulevard you
have the freedom to create a homeless
encampment under a freeway and even
light it on fire you have the the
freedom to uh have an open air drug
market and use drugs you have a freedom
if you're an illegal alien to get all
these taxpayer benefits so so those are
freedom they're not the freedoms our
founding fathers Envision but they have
contributed to the destruction of the
quality of life in California and the
results speak for themselves people are
leaving the state because they have
failed in addressing the homeless
population